so far critics and audiences alike seem
to be responding positively to zack
snyder's army of the dead
praising the genre-bending zombie movie
for its premise
its heart and its over-the-top action
sequences
the story follows a ragtag group of
mercenaries led by dave bautista's
scott wood as they travel through an
undead ridden las vegas in an effort to
retrieve a mountain of loot from a
casino vault
one of the most important members in
this carnage causing posse
is marianne peters a cigar chomping
helicopter pilot who's tasked with
safely flying the team out of the city
after the mission is complete 100 i
meant
yeah you don't want to know you know the
risks or why would i want to know the
risks
originally the comedian chris de lea was
supposed to play the pilot character
in army of the dead but he was fired
from the movie after becoming the
subject of investigations
into alleged sexual misconduct while
delia denies any wrongdoing
snyder and company had no reservations
about replacing him
in a recent interview with vanity fair
snyder revealed that the decision to
replace dalia was a fairly easy one
he also believes that tig notaro's
presence did a lot more than just make
some distance between the movie
and delia's scandals in fact the snyder
said that notaro's performance brought a
whole new unexpected dimension to the
film
the director explained i think the movie
is better with tig notaro
frankly because she's more unexpected
and she's more fun while they were
eventually able to turn their obstacle
into an opportunity
the filmmakers were very much aware of
the risks that came with replacing dalia
so late into the production according to
schneider the situation could have been
a disaster
if he didn't have the right team in
place fortunately his colleagues are
used to working on visual effects heavy
blockbusters
and so they eventually managed to
successfully replace taliyah without
making it too obvious in the final cut
but it certainly wasn't easy in fact
having to replace dalia with notaro gave
the filmmakers all kinds of headaches
first they had to erase every mention of
delia's character
and digitally insert tignotaro into the
scenes instead given that the situation
unfolded during the pandemic
reshooting the scenes with the actors
together wasn't an option
so they had to get creative and spend a
lot of money
during her interview with vanity fair
deborah snyder revealed that the cost of
adding the new actor
was equivalent to the entire budget for
army of thieves
the upcoming prequel to army of the dead
however
both she and her husband credited
netflix for doing the right thing
by putting their money where their mouth
is nataro's own health issues also posed
a problem for the snyders and their crew
as a cancer survivor it wouldn't
typically have been advisable for notaro
to make any movies during a pandemic
indeed deborah snyder admitted that
notaro was nervous about her health
potentially being compromised
but she pressed ahead with the project
anyway and thankfully didn't encounter
any issues during the shoot
of course some of notaro scenes in army
of the dead were obviously the product
of some expert digital wizardry
but at the moment really do make it seem
like she was part of the movie
the entire time in one scene that snyder
would soon have to cut
though taro is featured speaking to dave
bautista's character
as he leads the mercenaries down a
corridor he told vanity fair
when we first talked about it i was like
this is gonna be really hard because
they're all backlit and haloed
and there's a lens flare but it came out
perfectly i'm not trying to be the bad
guy
we should be incentivized to let him die
funnily enough while batista and notaro
have some surprisingly great chemistry
with each other in army of the dead
the former wwe champion still hasn't
been formally introduced to his co-star
while speaking to vulture batista said
that he feels like he has a connection
with notaro
due to the power of their scenes and it
bugs him that they still haven't been
acquainted he said
i feel like i should know her i want to
meet her and i want to hug her and tell
her how amazing she was in the film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one